19,1 milliard d'euros c'est le bénéfice
net de Total énergie pour 2022 le groupe
pétrolier et gazier est dégage un profit
record l'année même ou les Français ont
souffert du prix élevé des carburants
les réactions ont été immédiates jackpot
pour les destructeurs du climat réagi
Greenpeace ce matin et puis des
militants ont aspergé de rouge la façade
du siège de total pour dénoncer un méga
projet pétrolier en Ouganda
effectivement 20 milliards d'euros de
net de résultat net c'est un record
absolu mais ils disent qu'ils ont payé
dans le monde 33 milliards d'euros
d'impôts dans le monde plus de double
qu'en 2021 bah oui
mais il faut être c'est une entreprise
mondiale qui fait bénéfices ailleurs
qu'en France d'ailleurs d'ailleurs total
je pense que si total quittait la France
ça changerait peut-être pas grand chose
sur le bénéfice c'est important de le
dire plus de 42 milliards de dollars de
bénéfices pour Shell
plus de 55 milliards pour exson mobile
même au pays de l'argent roi c'est trop
pour le président Joe Biden
je trouve ça scandaleux ces entreprises
doivent bien faire ils plaident pour
plus de taxes mais à peu de chance de
convaincre les républicains qui
contrôlent une partie du Congrès on
pourrait vous imaginer travailler dans
l'univers automobile on voit que vous
maîtrisez le sujet moi dans le milieu de
l'automobile peut-être
alors on est là à part la mode et votre
chère voiture vous avez d'autres centres
d'intérêts qui pourraient nous aider à
découvrir votre métier
je sais pas comment on dit mais j'aime
trop trop voyager vous aimeriez partir
au Pérou rencontrer la famille d'Orfila
qui est votre fiancé tout à fait parce
que elle vient de là-bas
[Applaudissements]
on sent le on sent le Père Fouras
derrière là on écrit en lettres d'or les
lettres de la télévision française
d'ailleurs en avant un après vraiment au
21 millions de Français en salle c'était
il y a 25 ans Titanic Jack et Rose pour
l'éternité Titanic mais aussi cette
question il y avait-il de la place pour
deux sur cette planche question qui
hante mes nuits depuis un quart de
siècle une question à laquelle James
Cameron répond de manière scientifique
dans le cadre d'un documentaire sur le
film il plonge dans une piscine d'eau
Glac les acteurs de la même corpulence
que Kate Winslet et Leonardo DiCaprio
leur fait vivre tout ce qui se passe
dans le film à l'identique
[Musique]
bonsoir Nathalie
avec Franck et vous avez deux filles
Angèle et Valentine elles ont 15 et 11
ans permet de les saluer vous êtes
consultante
[Rires]
j'étais donc vraiment curieux de voir si
elle allait se passer dans cette
situation pour Jack et c'est assez
intéressant
ce que nous avons vu c'est qu'il est
monté dessus et il a immédiatement
commencé à greloter à trembler très fort
donc oui Jack aurait pu monter sur le
bout de bois aux côtés de rose mais il
serait alors mort de froid tous les deux
il faut absolument garder ses
chaussettes pendant l'acte c'est une
étude hollandaise qui le dit mais oui et
je m'adresse à toutes mes ex qui m'ont
demandé d'enlever les chaussettes et bah
il paraît que l'orgasme est meilleur
avec les chaussettes le corps est plus
chaud voilà pour prendre son pied
je vous remercie
selon mon expérience quand vous avez un
happy end cela fait trop Hollywood et en
fait les gens n'aiment pas ça
pour moi le film devait se terminer
comme ça
ma seule erreur dans toute cette
histoire c'est de ne pas avoir fait
cette année bout de bois plus petit il
n'y aurait eu aucun doute à ce sujet
46% des hommes Rémi des hommes français
admettent avoir déjà été infidèle dans
leur vie les femmes elles bien sûr sont
beaucoup plus sérieuses oui enfin de
très peu c'est ce que nous dit
l'Observatoire européen de l'infidélité
réalisé par le site de rencontre
extra-conjugales gidden
trois choses devant être retourné des
crêpes
et ta mère sous leurs yeux s'étale et
les milliers d'objets qu'ils ont
accumulés au fil des années 339 paires
de chaussures
111 casquettes
81 sacs à main
si 46% des hommes français admettent
avoir déjà été infidèle au cours de leur
vie tu l'as dit c'est quand même 38 %
pour les femmes je suis désolé surtout
la tendance s'inverse elle est tombée
pour les hommes 46% déclare aujourd'hui
avoir été infidèle au cours de leur vie
contre 55% en 2014 parce que les hommes
manquent
on est passé de 32% en 2014 à 38%
aujourd'hui parce que la parole se
libère
[Rires]
excusez-moi s'il vous plaît excusez-moi
s'il vous plaît
sa date de mon intervention
ah bah oui ce qui fait réagir ce matin
c'est une étude du ministère des Sports
les collégiens ont de moins en moins de
capacités physiques il court moins vite
et trois sur cinq ne savent pas
enchaîner trois sauts oui c'est
préoccupant les collégiens couraient à
10 km/h en 87 11 kg 11 km/h en 87 10
km/h aujourd'hui donc oui ça baisse ça
baisse bonjour je suis le professeur
brocoli scientifique de renommée qui
explique aux enfants les bienfaits des
légumes et des fruits et de
l'alimentation la plus saine possible
bonjour bonjour
on y va café
moi et je suis là
ça vous plaît les enfants oui c'est trop
trop bien le placard des vrais bonbons
on peut pas y accéder tout le temps ah
si c'est pas parce que je suis un mec
rentre que je peux pas l'atteindre avec
un tabouret
finalement gérer les enfants c'est pas
si compliqué on secoue un peu on leur
fait des souris on rigole un peu avec
eux
[Musique]
oui les enfants ne courent pas assez
vite mais en même temps Norman Jean-Luc
Lahaye Jean-Marc Morandini se sont fait
choper donc les collégiens n'ont plus
aucune raison de courir